okay you and I similar yeah I think so
many many movie choices were on a
similar wavelength
I think musical musically tell huh well
you yeah I think I think about me no
more I like I'm not hip to Red House
Painters I probably should be for
instance no but you know what though I
am hip to the Pixies yeah right yeah
I grew up with surfer rosa do little
bossa nova Trump Lomond right I grew up
with television Markie Moon all those
CBGB bands right I grew up with Joy
Division all that stuff right and I'm
gonna and this is this is the dick
sucking part I'm not gay but now I'm
only saying that because they pay but I
would just say that sorry but I have to
say it okay this is that um I honestly
believe that Interpol
right and is like to me a Joy Division
or a Pixies or pavement or even I was
also loved G be guided by voices growing
up you know I mean I loved alien lands
all those out like lo-fi albums but I'm
telling you right now that's I mean that
your [ __ ] even when you Julian plenty
and that's that song run I love you know
me it's so catchy right on if you run
yes no you wrote it right yeah this
right this dude I mean having you on I
mean I I'm not intimidated anymore I'll
tell you why because I know athletically
I have you superior no way witnesses
it's a proven fact right let eclis I'm
above you okay okay you know he's
actually one of the most agile people
think I've ever met he's a great great
ping-pong player
he's a great hockey player and also a
great tennis player oh I play tennis I
grew up playing tennis all right I'll
play tennis all right here's the deal
we're getting I think that one house
because at one house one by Nick Tennis
Club no not the Tennis Club House right
I'm buying a house right now things so
absurd the other day you passed by a
country club with tennis courts and he
was like oh I I want to sign up for that
place and those like well we have a free
one next door he's like
we play tennis where I can pay it feels
it feels better when you have a
membership right there's gonna be
somewhere where you can like buy a
sandwich right go to the bathroom right
yeah but then you have to [ __ ] share
it with people that you know what the
clubhouse yeah I like did you grow up
with did you go up with country clubs no
but with tennis clubs but with 10
o'clock yeah yeah what do they have then
pumped that public ones don't have
things like that like yeah freshmen area
somewhere to sit Here I am it's right
food you now run with more people and
we're doing our own yeah but there is
like you know you you know you you want
a electrolytes right yeah sure right
yeah you want bonbons
if you want a little you know treat
record it's hot all right and if Paul
and I were playing we don't have to wait
forever yeah I mean Julio and Juan are
playing
you mean with hockey sticks you know I
mean the public next I'm just saying it
right in the public one right yeah
there's a homeless guy sleeping in the
public when we have to wait for it up
for him to wake up I know if the surface
is [ __ ] up that's exactly that's you
like do you like clay what do you like
to play on oh I'm a grass man my solid
grass play on grass you bite Poway okay
yeah where I go up and we had grass ones
we just had a regular one but that's
like the rarest cuz it's the house I
call it never play on grass it's only
like Wimbledon I know French opens yeah
but so you have racquets Paul I do yeah
oh but they're in New York they're in
New York yeah okay here's what I want to
do with you yeah okay because I feel
like um I feel like you know like I'm
looking a little boy little lost you
know and I want you to be able to pick
up the sword right and swing at the UH
you know swing for the fences you know I
want you to be able to defend your pride
mm-hmm all right after the humiliation
of the yeah yeah yeah cuz that's that's
a that was a huge gigantic defeat on
your part I mean [ __ ] talk and ping-pong
right I understand and I respect love -
it feels good to win though it does yeah
yeah I will share how are you and [ __ ]
talk after after I defeat you yeah yeah
yeah cuz what I will say were - oh
you're up - oh yeah best of five so it's
not even really decisive I think that
you know I I want to be friends with you
so I let's just make it longer than five
let's make it at best of ten best of ten
yes yes the [ __ ] tennis we're human are
never gonna play tennis okay let's get
let's get real yeah ping pong ping pong
what we're buying a house now we're
gonna get out of here and in my we are
and now I just I I made a decision just
based on the ping pong yeah that one
place has area to put up a ping pong
we're putting a ping-pong inside yeah
it's gotta be inside that it's gotta be
inside the wind oh yeah I know but it
cannot be like in the middle of the
living it's not gonna live when if I can
go there right I'm gonna show you
tomorrow night we're gonna go look at it
again at night all right
good this is with a ping pong this is
where Paul's defeat happens this is
where you know min the man Paul banks
spiritually dies again this area right
he's got the talent only only to be
reborn
what's my backhand loose that night yeah
why did I mention that sometimes like
when I'm starting it gets a little you
know it's stiff and the balls kind of I
don't have my control right then I get
the topspin I get the whip go right whip
is going it's kind of like I don't know
I don't know if you're winning again I
don't know yeah no you were right I
think I recall you started getting
better and the reason why I bailed oh
that's why yeah
do you know and you know that's why
right I do not know that's why well did
you see him gradually become paler and
paler I was I was I could hear him
wheezing
I was bleeding internally I do remember
I I was sweating a lot actually yeah
yeah yeah we were still smoking like two
packs a day - oh that's right
[Music]